last video we get a little bit of
practice adding decimals that involved
tenths now let's do slightly more
complicated examples so let's say we
want to add four to five point seven or
we could read the second number as five
and seven tenths pause this video and
see if you can do this so the way that
my brain tries to tackle this is I try
to separate the whole numbers from the
tenths so you can view this as being the
same thing as four plus five plus seven
tenths all I did here is I broke up the
five and seven tenths into five plus
seven tenths and the reason why my brain
likes to do that is because I can then
say okay four plus five that's just
going to be equal to nine and then I
just have to add the seven tenths this
is going to be nine and seven tenths
which I can rewrite this is going to be
equal to nine and seven tenths and nine
and seven tenths I could write as nine
point seven and even though in future
videos we're going to learn other ways
of adding decimals especially larger
more complicated decimals this is still
how my brain adds four plus five point
seven especially if I need to do it in
my head I say okay 4 plus 5 is 9 and
then I have that seven tenths so it's
going to be nine and seven tenths or
nine point seven now let's do another
example where both numbers involve a
decimal so let's say I want to add six
point three to seven point four so six
point three plus seven point four once
again pause this video and try to work
through it on your own well my brain
does it the same way I break up the
whole numbers and the decimals and once
again there's many different ways of
adding decimals but this is just one way
that seems to work especially for
decimals like this so we could view this
as six and three tenths so I'm breaking
up the six point three is six and three
tenths into six plus three tenths
+7 and 4/10 7 plus 4 tenths and then
this you can view as so you could view
this as 6 plus 7 6 plus 7 plus plus 3
tenths plus 3 tenths plus 4 tenths plus
4 tenths so if you add the ones here you
have 6 ones and 7 ones that's going to
be equal to 13 and then 3 tenths and
4/10 well if you have 3 of something
then you add 4 of that that's going to
be 7 tenths and we would write 7 tenths
is 0.77 in the tenths place and then
what's 13 plus 7 tenths well that is
going to be 13 this is going to be equal
to thirteen point seven thirteen point
seven and we are done let me do one more
example that will get a little bit a
little bit more involved so let me
delete all of these so let's say I
wanted to add six point three two and
I'm going to add that to two point two
point nine pause the video and see if
you can figure this out well let's do
the same thing this is going to be six
and three tenths so 6 plus 3 tenths plus
two plus 9/10 or you could view this as
6 plus 2 so I'll put all my ones
together 6 plus 2 and then I'll put my
tents together plus 3 tenths plus 3
tenths plus 9 tenths plus 9 tenths and
so the 6 plus 2 is pretty
straightforward that is going to be
equal to 8 and now what's 3/10 plus 9
tenths this is going to get a little bit
interesting 3 tenths plus 9 tenths and I
can write it out I could say this is 3
tenths
this is 9/10 well three tenths plus 9/10
is equal to twelve tenths this is going
to be twelve tenths but how do we write
twelve
tenth as a number well 12 tenths is the
same thing as 10 tenths plus two tenths
and the reason why I broke it up this
way ten ten is one hole so this is going
to be equal to one so when you add these
two together it's twelve tenths which is
the same thing as 1 & 2 tenths so 1 plus
2 tenths or let me just write it that
way so this I can rewrite as plus 1 plus
2 tenths and then I think you see where
this is going I could add the 8 and the
1 and I get 9 and 2 tenths so 9 & 2
tenths so it's going to be nine point
two now the reason why this one was a
little bit more interesting is I added
the ones I got six plus two is eight but
then when I added the tenths I got
something that was more than a hole I
got what I got twelve tenths which is
one and two tenths and so I added one
more hole to the eight to get nine and
then I had those two tenths left over
and this is really good to understand
because in the future when you're adding
decimals you'll be doing stuff like
carrying from one place to another and
this is essentially what we did when we
added the three tenths plus the nine
tenths we got twelve tenths until we
added an extra hole and then we had the
leftover to ten hopefully that makes
some sense